so I'm curious do you guys consider all
the religions to be sort of equally bad
we could just start with the Western
ones first are we talking about ideology
are we talking about politics no well
it's hard to separate them at right now
in 2016 it's extremely hard to separate
yes it is and it isn't I mean you know
David can talk all he wants about how
ridiculous the belief in God is among
Jews and there's very slim chance that
are Jews going to blow up his car right
you know not true for every religion and
not true for everybody in every religion
so you know it's it's kind of a
constellation but so even there you're
sort of not saying which religion you're
talking oh well you know I'm not saying
all Muslims are terrorists but all
terrorists and Muslims say it's not a
hundred percent true there's some duty
absolutely no theater so it's what I
always said I would say back there there
were no atheist terrorists cuz no no you
never hear someone you could say I'm
gonna fly these planes into this
building cuz no God didn't call to tell
me not to I know it's funny that way
yeah and again you know we're getting
into the whole let's get into let's just
dive right into the Islamophobia yes an
area well let's just let's just stick
with the atheism terrorist thing for one
second because there is there was that
one guy in Sweden remember a couple
years ago that shot up that Slavic yeah
I think so and eros Knights of Templar
but there was some confusion I think at
one point whether he was atheist or
something like that now and I noticed
that a lot of my friends on the Left who
should be for should be promoting
atheist and promoting secular values
suddenly they loved the fact that he
either was an atheist or had to me at
these fast but even that in and of
itself doesn't prove that he did it in
the name of atheist but you also hear
about you hear about Stalin and Hitler -
that they were atheist but you know that
there was a Catholic but yes it's all
it's all a straw man which is you know
communist Trump's atheist
by a million miles right so that's
that's what I can never understand that
when I see this from my friends Oh
laughter Wow he was an atheist and he
did this like they're just waiting I
know the way they are sure and they're
just waiting for somebody
some Crazy Eights sure I'm saying and
then so they can pin it on them and then
they can pin it all the way up til they
get it to darken but he has no doctrine
atheist has no ideology atheism has no
Dogma you know that doesn't mean these
can't kill or be a bad words not of
course not right yeah but I mean it's so
enraging when people look for reasons to
blame a theist look people that the
terrorists the the the thing that we
have to get through when we talking
about religion we have to get into the
fact that all religion is individual
every single believer I can say
something about every single believer
they believe in a God that agrees with
them okay there's nobody out there that
says I believe in a man in the sky that
disagrees with the heat my god is
pro-choice but I don't think so okay
that doesn't happen everybody believes
in a God that agrees with them which
means those terrorists walking down the
streets of Paris shooting people in the
streets thought they were doing good
work they thought they were doing good
and the same with the Olympic Park
bomber is the same with with with the
Brussels bombers the same with the
people in the World Trade Center they
all thought they were doing good because
religion is individual and that means
the basis for religious terrorists and
the basis for religious extremism is
exactly the same as the basis for a
religious moderate ISM and religion
liberalism you're all making it up as
you go along and people don't like that
right because they want to say well no
no I have a book and the book says that
I'm right well the book also says that
you're wrong over here but we're
ignoring that part they want to have a
basis but if we're going to deal with
religious extremism we need to deal with
the fact that all religion is the same
it's not about one religion or another
it's not about extremism versus not
extremism it's about the people who are
doing it it's about the people who have
been raised in this religion cycle that
makes them think that their God wants
them to do some really bad [ __ ] right so
you would acknowledge that the doctor
look if we're just doing the Western
ones for a second okay doctrines are all
slightly different right the Old
Testament is extremely violent yeah
the New Testaments a little less violent
the Koran is very violent all right so
the doctrines are a little bit different
but it's not about the doctrines you
would say as much it's just how the
adherents view the DA it's a hundred
percent how the adherents through the
doc yeah are you gonna believe in Harry
Potter then all actually it's true - I
mean the bottom line is do you believe
in the protagonist so do you okay so
then here's where to me the religion
conversation gets really interesting
because is there any other mode of
thought or is there any other set of
beliefs that would allow people to do so
many crazy things could anyone
a Frenchman walk into that theater and
under the guise of anything be beyond
you know psychologically unstable or
something be but beyond that is there
any other set of beliefs beyond religion
that would allow someone to murder that
many innocent people no I think I think
Hitchens I believe said it best at it
good people do good things and bad
people do bad things but for good people
to do bad things that takes religion and
that's exactly he's exactly correct
people the the people who are that
though the worst terrorists in the world
think they're good people yeah they
think they're doing God's work those
people like I again back in in in Paris
they shooting children on the streets
guess what they thought they were doing
those children a favor
by sending them to heaven early they
expected to be rude well they don't
think it's going to happen there's kids
are in the video so he said Allah who
would make the decision and if they were
getting all that we know a dead kid
infidel ghost Allah - may Allah makes
all the decisions and then they'd they
they're setting him up to Allah for
judgment and if he's good he's going to
heaven Ya Allah
by the way radical Muslim terrorists are
responsible for a lot of Muslim deaths
for Muslim destiny exactly so yes it is
and that's because an infidel is just
somebody outside of your sect of what
right of Islam not necessarily your
right and and you know the same is true
for you know the Christian
fundamentalists who kill abortion
doctors yes they absolutely believe
they're doing good for unknown unnamed
children to come right you know and
that's one of the ones where the
political part of it is very coupled
with it because then you get rhetoric
for exact politician exactly and that's
what you now have
in Muslim extremism is the the notion
that Sharia law which is religious
doctrine should be political doctrine
should actually be global law it should
be the way the world runs and this is a
very very strongly and closely held
faith of their belief it's exactly the
same as Ted Cruz's dominionism that they
want and what does that mean well that
fundamentally means the religious
leaders rule the world well that goes
the religious leaders tell you what
Allah or God or Jesus wants repeatedly
that for all of my friends I was at a
party with you a couple weeks ago and
I'm talking to all these good la
liberals and everyone's going on and on
about how they hate Trump I've done
several videos how I do not support
Trump I don't like Trump but I but I
couldn't understand how they were all
more angry at Trump than Ted Cruz who
stands in stark complete opposition I
don't know what Trump believes that's my
issue with him more than yeah I'm not
sure what he's in New York I don't
really think he's against abortion in
reality and you know I mean like I think
he's just trying to make a sale okay I
think he should be president of a union
right that would release that he
couldn't name a single Bible verse yet
the thing is one sure name Genesis one
you know and we're at one time he sort
of cracked under pressure was at Liberty
University yeah you know so when he had
to pretend he was religious he sort of
cracked but I was talking about these
good LA liberals and they were all more
fearful and afraid of Trump than Ted
Cruz and I was trying to explain to them
that's the scarier guy in this equation
that's the guy if he became president
well there's a reason he might want to
ratchet up things in the Middle East
because this Armageddon thing right yeah
as well because if altima all that comes
to pass it's only what is it 144 people
with some 144,000 if we take that back
now we're going back to the label okay
now we're going back to the why it's my
business what people at a theist call
themselves if atheists are two and a
half percent of the population but we're
actually 27 percent of population the
Ted Cruz's are not gonna pay attention
to us and when we're talking about
closeted atheists we're talking about
foisting our power
away over to the Christian right we're
actually giving our power there if we as
atheists would call ourselves atheists
unify under a word and stop trying to
say no no I'm not an atheist I'm a
secular rationalistic Christian who
doesn't know you're an atheist if you
wouldn't unify if we can just come
together on this we have a social
responsibility to do that to stop the
Religious Right who has dominionist
tendencies who actually has people in
power who want to bring around the end
of the world I'm speaking literally now
yeah so that it's just hard to wrap your
brain around but it's like for regular
for regular people and I mean this for
myself too it's hard for me to believe
that if I'm to believe that Ted Cruz
believes the things that he says he
believes this goes back to your earlier
question the hardcore fundamentalist
dominionist Christians are no different
in ideology and fervency than the
radical Muslims right at this moment in
time they're not killing as many people
no but that's that that's just like
that's a technique and a strategy but
has nothing to do with the commitment
that they have to their ideals
you know the Christians are more
concerned with doing it politically but
but but Ted Cruz firmly believes that
subjugating the Constitution under his
version of the Bible is the good deed
and if we have an Armageddon type of
situation it'll be fine because God is
in control yeah we this is our problem
Dave if we talk about Ted Cruz and then
we take just a broader look we talked
about all the separation of church and
state issues we talk about abortion we
talk about death with dignity we talk
about LGBT rights we talk about the pay
gap these are our faults these issues
exist because atheists are in the closet
and that's why it's our responsibility
to come out that's why it's our
responsibility so many atheists say oh
you shouldn't tell me what I should call
yourself call myself yes I should
because what you call yourself affects
me yeah I love that link that you just
made there because that everything that
I've done on this show has been about me
trying to help the left which I see in
such such disrepair and
and being pulled by such bad forces so I
feel it's my duty to help the left and
now I see that absolute parallel for you
and the work that you're doing the
revolution eats its own children yeah
children I'm so man we've got these guys
so you must not have a lot of hope than
for our political future in this country
cuz it doesn't seem to be going away oh
I do I got a lot of hope yeah I mean
well let's talk about the politics for a
second okay we got a guy on there on the
left you've got a Bernie Sanders okay
he calls himself a non-religious Jew
yeah okay he's got is the first
political candidate with the word
non-religious attached to his name on
the other side we've got Donald Trump 2
Corinthians couldn't name Genesis one
couldn't name three John 3:16 ok go back
20 years could that have ever happened
right the religious right is freaking
out the religious right is pouring all
its support into Ted Cruz the religious
right is trashing Bernie Sanders for
being an atheist the religious right is
trashing Donald Trump for being an
atheist okay and everybody's talking
about it today nobody's talking about
Bernie Sanders Jerry Falwell Jr just
endorsed Donald Trump somebody who
couldn't name the Bible verses so why
we've gone from the writer just right
attacking the atheists and throwing
their support behind religious
candidates to being quiet about the
atheists and supporting the candidates
that are already winning in order to
ride coattails we are seeing the the
evaporation of the religious right
privilege I mean yeah we've still got a
lot of ways to go but we're seeing a
rise in atheists on a conservative side
we're seeing a rise in people calling
themselves atheists more on a state to
state level than anybody else and we're
seeing people getting really really
intolerant of people saying I want my
Jesus to be you know the king of the the
king of the land we are making really
serious headway it's just taking time
yeah it's kind of happened in our
lifetimes so I know that there's a
certain amount of people that are gonna
watch this and they're gonna say but
your secular values they are not derived
of some sort of innate goodness you know
I mean that seems to be a big thing
that's that's what mother just values
yeah
so that's the answer to that someone
says that to you yeah yeah I you know
I'll go I'll go head to head with Jim
Baker any day you want yeah let's go
talk about how much money of you
embezzled from zero come on Pat
Robertson let's talk blood diamonds yeah
blood diamonds let's let's let's talk
about these values I mean there's a
commandment against rape to get slavery
it's also yeah right it's also
astonishing that people still give money
in droves to somebody who claims that
God wants them to have a private jet you
know and I think that's why a lot of
far-right candidates who Dominion a
dominionists like or or espouse that
sort of stuff publicly like like a Ted
Cruz I think a lot of the support for
them also sits back and goes well he
doesn't really mean that he's just
saying that to get the idiots on board
you know he's just saying that to get
the lowest common denominator on board
but he doesn't really believe there
himself which is a whole other question
I don't know what's right or wrong as
far as that goes but but I don't think
people really believe that it's
dangerous and it is really dangerous New
Atheists the phrase new Athey
you consider yourself a new eighth I
consider myself an old atheist on the
new part about New Atheism we keep
talking about people being offended when
you attack their religion and I
mentioned before about people you know
being conned and scammed
the thing about New Atheists is that
we're not granting religion the
privilege that it wants right so that's
how you would define it that's the only
difference
that's the beliefs the lack of belief
system is exactly the way older than
religion yeah but I mean Madalyn Murray
O'Hair didn't respect religion so it's
not new new is the wrong word but we're
talking about an open acknowledgement of
the fact that no I do not respect your
belief I respect you as a person but
your belief is stupid and it's going to
and I'm not going to respect it just
because you say it and that is what
makes us in your face yeah when I call
religion a myth which it is when I call
religion a scam which it is I'm being in
your face I'm being oppressive and
obtrusive I'm not there not though when
they're you right there when they're on
the other side of it that's all good
right right right so and there's this
this
that religion has had for centuries we
here in this country you know the fact
that they pay no taxes the fact that
they they are they get special parking
well all that sort of stuff I mean it's
it's what religious use was intellectual
part yeah you get a clergy don't get it
you're an atheist oh I mean it's crazy
it's not crazy
and I understand you're confusing being
handicapped with religious big churches
come in the police
direct traffic and he's talking about
all these things that the public pays
for that churches get because the
churches say so yeah you know the tax
exemption that churches get because the
churches say so the parking help the
police the fire all of that stuff that
the churches get because the church says
so is a function of religious privilege
and it puts non-religious people on a
second-class status
yeah so wait I want to circle back to
something you just said about the ideas
and people because I've repeatedly if
probably every week I just heard it was
the 32nd episode that we've done here I
think pretty much in 32 shows I always
make the distinction between ideas
meaning and we're talking about Islam
that Islam itself the religion is a set
of ideas and Muslims are the people that
practice it and I deserve respect based
on how they practice their religion just
like anyone else would I try to make
that over and over no matter how many
times I do it right X amount of people
just can't they can't get there but at
some point and I've had a lot of people
say this to me and I think there might
be some truth to it at some point can
those things not be separated
you know you mean at some point when you
Whittle it down and you keep whittling
it down as you said you want to respect
the person but not the belief but at
some point the person who has the belief
how do you respect that well religious
people are victims of scams of a scam
okay they're victims they're not stupid
and they're not immoral and they're not
[ __ ] or anything like that they are
victims of a scam and my mother was a
victim of a scam and grandmother was a
victim of a scam and and there but for
dumb luck oh we right if we were raised
and fundamentalist households we might
be victims of the same scam we do need
to I mean where do you draw the line as
what you asked I draw the line
when I'm talking to somebody and I
reason with them and they say yeah
you're right Dave but I'm gonna choose
to believe anyways you can't choose to
believe you only can choose to pretend
to believe right you can't choose to
believe back I UK that's what belief is
I mean that's just no there's a big
difference between if at this
conversation let go yeah I had a button
I'm gonna destroy the world unless you
truly believe the world is flat right
got it you can't force me to believe but
I can choose to say you can choose to
pretend to believe okay okay and when
you start choosing to pretend to believe
now you're talking about somebody who's
making a choice now you're talking about
somebody yeah that I would judge on a
larger level I mean if somebody is
choosing to be a bad person or is
choosing to live a lie because they're
too cowardly or stubborn to admit that
they have been acting wrongly then yes I
judge them on an individual level but
for when they're talking about religious
believers no religious believers aren't
stupid and on the on the high end
religious believers are not stupid
they're not morons they are victims
which makes it our prerogative to help
them just like if they were victims of a
used car salesman or homeopathy or
astrology or tarot card readers or any
others for an internet scam or the
internet scam it is our job as humanists
as nice people to help these people away
from that scam right that's a big
mountain to climb though because people
don't want to view themselves as victims
tough [ __ ] there's direct UM's that's it
I mean yeah that you atheists that so do
atheist it's it's too bad we have to
deal with facts now we have to put on
our big people pants and deal with facts
religion is a scam believers are victims
and it's a good thing to help people
away from it and the amount of evidence
for religion equals the amount of
evidence for tarot card readers and
other scams and psychics zero it's a lie
it's a scam it's a con and killing it
dead is a good deed I wish this guy
could be a little clearer on what he's
trying to see a little clarity well you
should read his book would be
behind on my I know what are you making
a pecking order of religion the way we
talk about religion so right like we
could all very easily make fun of
Mormonism right now and people would go
crazy and they'd love it it's the
easiest thing you can do right right
well that's also you know a lot of
Christians are complaining that uh you
know you can make fun of us but you
can't make fun of Islam or what do I do
you know yeah Muhammad openly and I
think everybody should draw Mohammed so
I agree with you because just because
someone believes something doesn't mean
it should control what I'm able to do
with my brain and my body it's not
blasphemy if you don't believe our day
but there's what they think it is and
and right and that's the that's the
inherent danger look Charlie Hebdo
didn't they say that they're not going
to draw pictures of Muhammad anymore I
mean I'm pretty sure me no I don't
believe they said that there are
hundreds of thousands of religious laws
in this world and none of them have any
authority over us whatsoever okay they
all have that in common and I'm reminded
of a story that Penn told me once that
wasn't his joke but man walked up to
another man notices that he's got a
mason ring on says oh I see you're
wearing a mason ring first guy says yeah
I got a real nice ring it's a nice ring
first guy says well you must be a Mason
then second guy says no no I just like
the ring first guy says well it's
against Mason law for you to wear the
ring unless you're a Mason the second
guy says well it's a good thing I'm not
a Mason done right we can obey we we
have a freedom in this country and we
need to protect it and when they say you
have to root you have to observe our
religious laws you you don't get to draw
a thing anymore you don't get to say a
word anymore you don't get to wear your
hair like that anymore because it's
against our law it offends us we're the
ones who should take offense at that
right so you better wake up now we like
that's the key thing if you look back at
those at the Danish cartoon protests
you'll see a very common theme do not
draw Mohammed in the protests and
everybody in the world said we will not
yield to terrorism and then everybody
yield to terrorism and now I'm a
provocateur if I draw Muhammad but now
look at the more recent protests they
don't say do not draw Mohammed anymore
they say do not insult Islam because
when you leave when you yield a point to
terrorism it's never the last point you
will yield
they're always going to make more baby
steps so it is our prerogative as as
American citizens for our children to
protect every single right if they tell
you that you can't sit exactly in that
position it's your job to sit in exactly
in that position as much as you want it
more than your prerogative it's your
dude it is your duty as a human it is it
really is that's why I draw Mohammed
every time I can and I think everybody
should yeah well I will see what happens
on tie yeah you know what and it's it's
fine let's do it and you know it's if
you if you by fighting God there's a
section in fighting God where I could
where I drew Mohammed or the stick
figure and I actually had to draw this
and label it not Mohammed because if I
drew it as Mohammed they wouldn't put it
in the bookshelves right I literally has
yield to terrorism in order to publish
fighting god god that's depressing all
right god that's oppression there you go
all right so we only have two minutes
left so I want to try to end this in
let's move away from terror for a second
let's get a little peace to end this
thing with so I just took my so let's
talk about a reason rally but I just
took nine days off I was off of the grid
for nine days I literally had my phone
locked in a you know safe and I wasn't
on Twitter and I didn't watch TV until
today this all now I'm back it's good to
be back welcome home but it was great to
be off and what I did I was on a beach
in Mexico and I read I read Sam Harris
is waking up which is a guide to
spirituality without religion I thought
it was great because there is a
component to being human about a need
for spirituality and to be connected
with other people and finding some sort
of mental clarity and all that stuff
that I think you should want and strive
for without religion so my final
question to you guys and then bring it
to the Reiser alley and then we got a
wrap is is there anything that you guys
do in your life to get a little
spiritual nourishment yeah for me for me
it's art it's it's its beauty it's art
it's music it's comedy it's laughter
it's joy it's all those things but I
also feel like you know religion
certainly the judeo-christian religions
that you know that gave human beings
dominion over over the earth I think
that's a big place where it all kind of
went south because we have removed
ourselves from nature and I think the
more we realize that we coexist with
nature that we're a part of nature that
we are
not something above or below nature we
are we're in the Philippines we're in
the ecosystem etc etc etc so I do
believe that that just the the natural
world and the way nature exists and you
know the fact that we're all made of
Stardust
Montgomery know as spirituality I don't
know what would and it's the opposite of
a Supreme Being or any sort of fiction
it's right here or yeah it's right it's
right very second you know good finish
Paul Provenza bring us home Silverman I
like activism activism gives me a lot of
awe because I can help people I can see
the amount of change that people are
seeing I can see the evolution of people
on an individual level and I love that I
love watching people expand beyond their
comfort and role roles and I love doing
it myself
I do a lot of reading and I do a lot of
contemplating I've been doing a lot of
that in the past couple of years and and
I've grown as a person on a regular
basis as much as I can and I find that I
think that's a very important thing for
us all to do but really if where I get
my uh where I get my spirituality is
from helping people away from the lie of
religion and when people write to me and
tell me their stories and and and they
read the book and they they go on to
they come to an American atheist
convention or they come to the reason
rally I get a very beautiful sense of
awe reason rally one I know we're about
to go into it but um it was annexed it
was my most awe-inspiring mall it really
truly was I mean it was it was beautiful
it was it was beautiful oh yes it was
uplifting it was there was such a
connection and a community of thousands
of fat tens of thousands of strangers
atheists in the rain there was a vibe oh
it rains God made it rain it was the
closest thing that I could imagine
people mean when they say they're having
a religious experience
and it was about celebrating non-belief
I was about celebrating everything other
than fiction all right listen we really
have to wrap but clearly we could go on
forever so reason rally is just reason
rally org it's reason rally org its June
4th 2016 American atheist is that
atheists org and fighting God is name of
my book it's available everywhere you're
doing the full outro I am gonna be
fantastic
yeah on the comedy in which I'll talk
about Margaret Cho Lizz Winstead myself
Penn Jillette
who else show from there so I'm a comedy
perspective we're also talking about
Matt Amber Heard amber her of course our
star is Johnny Depp Johnny Johnny's do
happens given some hours the James Randi
is going to be there we're gonna have
Bill Nighy we're going to have Lawrence
Krauss we're gonna have all the atheist
ready to music and we're gonna have whoo
tang clan members it's coming up and do
routine clam use again and it's gonna be
the most amazing experience it's gonna
be the largest atheist event in world
history and it's a party and it's a
party we're not protests it's not a
protest it's it's it's called a rally
but it's much more of a party we wanted
fun we weren't Washington right in the
thick of it we want Washington to see
that anybody any member of government
that wants to defy the Christian Right
or any other religious based doctrinaire
Enterprise that has support yeah all
right well I asked God for five more
minutes and he did not give it to me
well we have to wrap this but it's
really been a pleasure guys and I'll
have you both on again to talk about
this and there's also a lot of other
things that you guys like talking about
you already pimped yourself out so I did
well stay on the book again oh yeah it's
fighting God right is a true Pro all
right I want to thank David Silverman
and Paul Provenza for joining me you can
file them both on Twitter at Paul
Provenza and at mr. atheist pants or
just follow them to hell your choice all
right thanks for all you guys